No, seriously, this.
I have lived in this thing since I got it.
Today I'm wearing it with like a little dress underneath,
but still, it's just the cutest little thing.
You know what I really love is you can button these buttons down here
and it looks like it's one of the quarter zip UPS,
you know, like a quarter pullover,
cause of the way the detail is right here.
I fucking love it. It is the perfect weight for the current temperature.
You don't need a full on jacket,
you don't need a full on coat,
but like, just a shirt isn't enough
or you just want something to throw over.
I absolutely love it. My boyfriend is complimenting.
He's like, oh,
my rich lady friend, my kid,
everybody loves it. I have.
If you haven't gotten one,
get it before they run out. It's linked right here.